[Applaus]
[Musik]
kristallklares wasser endlose strände
undurchdringlicher dschungel und
landschaften die uns das paradies vor
augen führen die philippinen sind ein
abgelegenes und unbekanntes landtags
dennoch eine bedeutende historische
verbindung mit spanien und irgendwie
auch mit vielen hispanischen ländern
lateinamerikas hat
[Musik]
diese ehemalige kolonie in südostasien
waren mehr als drei jahrhunderte lang
teil des spanischen weltreichs nach der
niederlage der spanischen truppen gegen
die usa im jahr 1898 wurden die
philippinen dann für 20 millionen dollar
an die gewinner verkauft
inflationsbereinigt während das etwa 620
millionen in heutigen dollars und ja
damals wurden ganze länder ganze
kolonien verkauft als wären sie einfache
strand grundstücke auch in diesem fall
wurden ganze länder zur
verhandlungsmasse der jeweiligen ep
riehen dass eine befand sich am ende
seiner existenz und das andere gerade
erst am anfang natürlich waren die
vereinigten staaten weit davon entfernt
der kolonie die unabhängigkeit zu geben
oder zumindest die zustände dort zu
verbessern so dass die freiheit für die
filipinos ausblieb
nach dem verkauf an die amerikaner
wurden die philippinen fast fünf
jahrzehnte lang von den usa regiert bis
sie endlich 1946 ihre unabhängigkeit
erlangten seitdem war der weg dieses
landes nicht gerade ein zuckerschlecken
sondern eher gefüllt mit salzigen tränen
brutale diktaturen korruption gewalt
drogenhändler islamischer extremismus
irgendwie schaffen es die philippinen
jeweils ein stück der schlimmsten
probleme so weit entfernte länder wie
venezuela honduras und pakistan unter
einem dach zu vereinen und um all diese
probleme zu bekämpfen haben sie jetzt du
tertre
rodrigo tat ist derzeit der präsident
der philippinen und obwohl er
demokratisch studiert wurde gibt es
derzeit nur wenige oder gar keine sagen
wir mal ein zeichen von demokratie ganz
im gegenteil schaut es euch selbst an
philippinischer bürgermeister auf
dotiertes nako liste erschossen eine
politik des abschlachten die sich gegen
die armen der philippinen richtet die
drogenbekämpfung politik von präsident
rodrigo dotierte hat seit 2016 zu mehr
als 20.000 toten geführt ja ihr habt
richtig gehört wir reden hier von
regelrechten außergerichtlichen
hinrichtungen die philippinische
regierung hat dieses sogar legalisiert
unglaublich nicht in diesem land über
das wir leider noch immer viel zu wenig
wissen
also möchtest du mehr über dieses ferne
land und die dunkle gestalt des rodrigo
du tertre erfahren gut an aufgießen
die philippinen ein land der extreme
zunächst einmal wäre es eine gute idee
das land über das wir hier sprechen ein
bisschen besser kennen zu lernen oder
und ich muss dir verraten dass wir hier
über eine sehr ungewöhnliche nation
sprechen einerseits handelt es sich um
das erste land in ganz asien dass eine
verfassung bekommen hat die von einem
jedenfalls teilweise gewählten kongress
verabschiedet wurde das geschah in
späten neunzehnten jahrhundert
in der kurzen zeitspanne zwischen dem
ende der spanischen herrschaft und der
us-invasion gab es eine kurzlebige
internationalen nicht anerkannte
republik die außerhalb ihrer eigenen
grenzen als republik mal los bekannt war
aber nachdem die amerikaner 20 millionen
dollar für diese inseln bezahlt hatten
war er natürlich klar dass dieses gebiet
ihr persönliches eigentum war jegliche
art von unterstützung für die
unabhängigkeit wurde als kriminelle
handlung betrachtet und 1906 verhafteten
und exekutierten amerikanische truppen
mitglieder der letzten regierung
republik darunter auch ihren präsidenten
general makarios tag ein der tod wird
für uns alle früher oder später ereilen
deshalb möchte ich ruhig vor dem
allmächtigen herren stehen aber ich
möchte euch sagen dass wir keine
banditen oder diebe sind wie es uns die
amerikaner vorwerfen sondern mitglieder
der revolutionären kraft die unser
mutterland den philippinen start-ups
lang lebe die demokratie und hoffentlich
wird unsere unabhängigkeit in der
zukunft wiedergeboren werden lang leben
die philippinen makarios iii meine
lieben zuschauer die philippinen sind
ein extrem vielfältiges land um euch nur
eine vorstellung davon zu geben die 110
millionen einwohner sprechen 170
verschiedene sprachen was für ein
babylonisches durcheinander und das ist
nicht mal das größte problem des landes
obwohl das land bis zur corona krise 20
jahre lang kein einziges quartal mit
negativen wachstum erlebt hatte und
obwohl das durchschnittliche
wirtschaftswachstum in den letzten zehn
jahren bei fast sechs prozent pro jahr
lang gelten die philippinen nach wie vor
als ein sehr armes land und im jahr 2020
schrumpfte die wirtschaft des landes
laut iwf zudem um 8,3 prozent und wurde
damit nach thailand das am
zweitstärksten betroffene land ein land
in dem der durchschnittslohn nur etwas
mehr als 200 dollar pro monat beträgt
wobei eine der wichtigsten quellen des
wohlstands die fast 30 milliarden dollar
sind welche mehr als zwölf millionen
philippinos aus dem ausland weltweit
jedes jahr in form von überweisungen an
ihre familien schicken
und dazu kommen noch die probleme der
regierung ein land zu kontrollieren dass
mehr als 7000 inseln schlechter
infrastruktur und 170 verschiedenen
sprachen besteht und damit ist der
perfekte nährboden für das aufkommen von
nicht empfohlenen aktivitäten gesät
[Musik]
armut sowie die fehlende kontrolle der
regierung und des rechtssystems über
einen großen teil des landes haben die
philippinen zu einem der größten
asiatischen epizentrum für menschen und
auch drogenhandel gemacht in ostasien
sind die philippinen nicht nur der
größte konsument von mit amphetaminen
und marihuana sondern auch ihr größter
produzent und rate mal woher die meisten
der im land operierenden kartelle kommen
nun ihr aus china und da kannst du dir
vorstellen was das so mit sich bringt
[Musik]
wie auch in anderen ländern in denen
diese matthias existieren sind gewalt
und der mangel an sicherheit ein großes
problem um diese drogen auf die herum
ist ein ganzes netz illegaler
wirtschaftszweig entstanden die sich den
menschen und organhandel dem schmuggel
aller art und praktische jeder anderen
kriminellen aktivität mit einem die du
dir vorstellen kannst natürlich ist da
die korruption als ein weiterer
wirtschaftszweig fast schon
institutionalisiert
die armut hat natürlich viele familien
dazu gezwungen sich in die arme einer
der vielen unterwelt gangs zu begeben
die im land aktiv sind und wie wir sehen
werden taucht vor diesem hintergrund die
figur des ducato auf ein präsident der
sich im wesentlichen durch zwei dinge
auszeichnet eine politik der harten hand
eine kompromisslose linie gegen die
kriminalität und das versprechen
wirtschaftlichen wachstums wenn es um
letzteres geht will er die karten neu
mischen und die strategischen partner
wechseln
die philippinen stehen nämlich der
vereinigten staaten seit sehr vielen
jahren sehr nahe so sehr dass washington
seine beziehung zu den philippinen als
special einstuft und die nation neben
ländern wie taiwan südkorea oder
thailand als einen seiner wichtigsten
strategischen verbündeten in asien
betrachtet seit dem amtsantritt von
präsident notierte im jahr 2016 hat sich
die achse manila washington jedoch
zunehmend in richtung peking verschoben
vor allem in den letzten zwei jahren
schauen wir mal an was für ein wandel
sich vollzogen hat mai 2017 du tertre
sagt chinas ski drohe mit krieg wenn die
philippinen nach öl bohren april 2018
der philippinische präsident rotary
produkte sagt er brauche china und liebe
ski jumping ich brauche china mehr als
irgendjemand sonst brauche ich china in
diesem moment ich liebe shipping einfach
er hat verstanden er versteht mein
problem und ist bereit mir zu helfen
also möchte ich mich bei china bedanken
rotring gute präsident der philippinen
eines ist klar dotierte braucht geld
viel geld investitionen und soviel
chinesisches kapital wie er sich
schnappen kann um die wirtschaft des
landes anzukurbeln er könnte dabei mit
seinen intentionen transparenter nicht
sein unser schicksal liegt in asien
nicht im nahen osten denn die sind zu
sehr mit kämpfen beschäftigt und haben
kein geld wenn du kein geld hast bist du
nicht mein freund also gehe ich nach
china da gibt es viel geld präsident
überrascht dich diese aufrichtigkeit nun
wohl nur deshalb weil du unseren front
und hatte noch nicht gut genug gäste
ist alles andere als ein normaler
präsident und in gewisser weise ist es
ja auch logisch dass eine diktatoren wie
skispringen besser auskommt als
mitführen westlicher demokratien gut in
den jahren davor musste sich die
philippinische regierung etwas von
peking distanzieren im jahr 2016
entschied der ständige schiffe in den
haag zu gunsten der philippinen in bezug
auf ihre souveränität über einen teil
des ost meeres was von china bestritten
wird aber zurück zu unseren diktatoren
welcher missetaten wird du tertre denn
eigentlich beschuldigt aufgepasst
[Musik]
du tertre der härteste präsident aller
zeiten
falls es etwas gibt das rot rekrutierte
seit beginn seiner präsidentschaft
auszeichnet dann dass er ein präsident
ist der klartext spricht und nicht herum
albert sagen das mal so wenn es ohne
skrupel geht ja so was kennt er
überhaupt nicht er ist bereit alles zu
tun was nötig ist um nicht nur den
drogenhandel und die kriminellen zu
bekämpfen sondern auch seine eigenen
politischen widersacher seine harte art
und weise hat ihm in der ganzen welt den
ruf eingebracht ein diktator und tyrann
zu sein der die grundlegendsten
menschenrechte nicht respektiert zum
beispiel was während der korona krise
geschäfte versprach die quarantäne auf
totalitäre weise durchzusetzen um jeden
preis dude erstes antwort auf das corona
die egos erschießt sie einfach meinen
befehl an die polizei und das militär
wenn es ärger gibt oder eine situation
entsteht in der leben auf dem spiel
steht erschießt sie verstanden nein
betont ich werde dich ins grab schicken
stellen die regierung nicht auf die
probe rodrigo du tertre und nur zwei
tage nach diesen aussagen würde ein 63
jähriger bauer von der polizei
erschossen weil er keine maske trug nach
angaben der beamten bedrohte der mann
sie mit einer sense verhältnismäßigkeit
was zum teufel ist das in diesen
gewollten klima der brutalität hat die
zahl der erschießungen von zivilisten
durch die polizei im ganzen land
zugenommen das wird von den
strafverfolgungsbehörden auch nicht
vertuscht
jeder der zur falschen zeit draußen ist
wird erschossen ihr [ __ ]
philippinische polizist in einem
radiobeitrag und das ist immer noch
nicht alles auf anweisung der regierung
wurden in einigen gemeinden menschen die
beim überschreiten der ausgangssperre
erbe stunden im hundezwinger gesperrt in
anderen orten wurden so drakonische
strafen verhängt dass man sie sehr
leicht mit folter verwechseln könnte wir
sind aber weit entfernt von schlägen und
reizgas welche die indische polizei
gegen widerspenstige menschen aus führt
welche die korona maßnahmen der modi
regierung nicht respektieren aber
natürlich hat diese ganze entwicklung
nicht mit krone angefangen
du tertre ist ein typ der einfach nicht
eine rehabilitierung und
resozialisierung glaubt seiner meinung
nach sind straftäter nichts anderes als
entbehrlicher sozialer abfall dies hat
er schon oft betont und genau aus diesem
grund hatte eine null toleranz strategie
gegenüber drogenhändlern und
drogenkonsumenten eingeführt seit er an
der macht ist hat er außerdem eine
schulpolitik angeordnet einen
regelrechten schießbefehl
das sind klare verletzungen der
grundlegendsten menschenrechte und die
erfahrungen auf den philippinen zeigen
uns dass dieses harte vorgehen nicht der
beste weg ist um die kriminalität zu
bekämpfen du tertre hat einfach eine
ganze maschinerie außergerichtlicher
hinrichtungen in gang gesetzt eine
maschinerie der absoluten macht und
willkür und wie wir alle wissen führt
absolute macht immer zu absoluten
missbrauch die extremen maßnahmen und
befugnisse haben der polizei fielen
beamten unter regierung tor und tür
öffnet ihnen unliebsame menschen
ungestraft loszuwerden und das in einem
land in dem das maß an korruption und
willkür sowieso schon sehr hoch ist
wir erinnern uns da zum beispiel an das
massaker von maguindanao im jahr 2009
bei dem 57 menschen eines kondoms von
einem rivalisierenden politischen klaren
überfallen wurden und ich möchte dir
eine frage stellen würdest du es wagen
nicht in einem solchen umfeld gegen die
regierung zu stellen oder gar die
machenschaften eines polizisten
anzuprangern ich wette das würdest du
allein aus angst nicht tun
seit der ersten einführung der null
toleranz politik oder vielleicht sollte
man sie eher 0 menschenrechte politik
nennen sind auf den philippinen nach
angaben der polizei schätzungsweise
mindestens 6600 menschen ums leben
gekommen human rights watch und der
internationale strafgerichtshof in den
haag schätzen die zahl jedoch gar auf
30.000 der internationale
strafgerichtshof in den haag hat sogar
die einleitung einer untersuchung gegen
seine regierung wegen verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit zugelassen
[Musik]
viele dieser menschen hatten nichts aber
rein gar nichts mit drogen handeln mafia
oder anderen kriminellen aktivitäten zu
tun waren einfach nur bürger die ins
kreuzfeuer der korruption geraten sind
oder eben aus zufall zur falschen zeit
am falschen ort waren im vergangenen
jahr hat das nobelkomitee in oslo den
philippinischen redakteurin maria rita
den friedensnobelpreis für ihre
berichterstattung über die härte und
seine unsauberen praktiken verliehen
pate ist aber gerade dabei sie wegen
verleumdung vor gericht zu zerren und
was schätzt du wie die einwohner der
philippinen ihren präsidenten angesichts
der geschilderten zustände bewerten nun
liebe zuschauer haltet euch fest der
rodrigo dotiertes beliebtheitswerte
liegen bei 80 prozent kommt schon das
ist nur ein bisschen weniger als völlige
hingabe und anbetung aber wie um alles
in der welt kann ein typ wie du tertre
so viel zustimmung bei der bevölkerung
bekommen
[Musik]
nun es mag in unserer kultur schwer zu
akzeptieren seien aber in ein land das
von kriminalität drogenhandel
menschenhandel und armut geprägt ist ist
es kein wunder dass für viele menschen
dinge wie freiheit und menschenrechte
weit in den hintergrund treten laut
umfragen hat nur 15 prozent der
philippinischen bevölkerung die
demokratie so wichtig und am ende
passiert das was wir schon viele andere
male gesehen haben ein teures kreis ein
cocktail aus verzweiflung enttäuschung
und korruption ist eben das
erfolgsrezept mit denen als autoritäre
führer an der macht bleiben kann die
nächsten wahlen auf den philippinen
stehen im mai dieses jahres an dort
verfasste und konnte nicht für eine
zweite amtszeit als präsident
kandidieren eine zeit lang gab es jedoch
gerüchte dass er einfach als
vizepräsident seiner tochter die dann
als präsidentschaftskandidaten antritt
weiterregieren will es wurde sogar
vorgeschlagen dass sie beide für zwei
verschiedene parteien kandidieren und
ihre siegeschancen zu erhöhen man sieht
also dass sich der ducati klaren wir
keine undemokratischen und moralisch
fragwürdigen tricks herein zu schade ist
aber die spekulationen haben jetzt ein
ende schließlich präsentierte produkte
2022 seine kandidatur für einen
senatorenposten nur um diese kurz darauf
wieder zurückzuziehen seine tochter wird
gegen manny pacquiao antreten einen
ehemaligen box weltmeister der seit 2016
im philippinischen senat sitzt und piano
ist jemand der auch mit der brutalen
anti drogen kampagne des derzeitigen
präsidenten sympathisiert der sohn von
rodrigo dotiert dass sebastian
kandidiert außerdem für das amt des
bürgermeisters von da wo mit 17
millionen einwohnern die drittgrößte
stadt der philippinen die auch sein
vater bereits regiert hatte bevor er zum
präsidenten gewählt wurde es bleibt also
spannend auf den philippinen und wir
werden die lage dort weiterhin im auge
behalten ist also bitte nicht unseren
kanal geht es zu abbonieren um immer auf
dem laufenden zu bleiben aber jetzt hast
du erst mal die möglichkeit die inhalte
dieses videos zu respektieren hat ein
präsident betonte das recht die
menschenrechte zu missachten auch wenn
er ein ziel verfolgt das theoretisch gut
sein könnte ist der kampf gegen das
verbrechen wichtiger als freiheit recht
und gerechtigkeit glaubst du du würdest
du jemanden wie du tertre in deinem land
haben wollen wie immer sind sie auf
deine meinung zu diesem thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe also dass dieses
video gefallen hat was ja gebt uns bitte
einen like empfehle ist eine freundin
vergiss das abo mit glöckchen nicht um
keine unserer videos messer verpassen
und unterstütze unserer arbeit wird auch
mit einer kleinen spende über den link
in der beschreibung unter diesem video
macht gut und bis bald